[موسيقى]
طرز اديم الجزيره العربيه بجبال تخللت
سهولها وسهوبها واغوارها وانجادها وتلونت
بالوان اجزائها الطبيعيه فهي كما قال
تعالى جدد بيض وحمر مختلف الوانها وغرابيب
سود وهي اعلام يقتدى بها وحصون يلوذون بها
عند الملمات
واكنان تقيهم الحر والبرد ومستودعات
للمياه واشجار
للمراعي
المعمره عرفت كل قبيله بجبلها او جبالها
وحفلت اشعارهم بذكرها والتغني بها
واضيفت ايامهم ايام العرب ووقائعهم
فتغنت قبيله طي بجبليها اجى وسلمى وعبس
بجبلها قطن وجهينه بربوه
وحنيفه بجبلها العار وتمييب بالعرمه وهذيل
بكبكب وسليم بشروره وكل قبيله بجبالها
فقل ان يخلو شعرهم من ذكر سهلان والنير
واجبله وتخفه وشعبه والهب وخزاز وحرى
وثبير وحضن وجبل تهل بعسير والكور برانيا
ويذبل اللي صبحه نجد
وجبل عمايه برمل السر وغيرها من جبال
الجزيره العربيه والخالده ولربما كانت
مواطن حب وملاعب صبا ومدارج عواطف
[موسيقى]
بكل مره يعود فيها الى فضاء الخطى يدرك ان
الانسان لم يمر منهنا بدون ان يترك اثرا
او حكايه
حكايات كثيره كلها تلتقي في المكان
ويجمعها الزمان
يقال انما حدث يوما لا يتكرر ويقال ايضا
ان التاريخ يعيد نفسه وفي الحالتين هناك
مكان ينتج زمانه مكان صامت يتحدث عن حروب
وتجاره ومعاهدات وغدر وعن شجاعه وموت
وحياه وحب هنا مسرح عارضي اليمامه
[موسيقى]
وجبل العرب هو اشهر جبال الجزيره العربيه
بعد سلسله جبال السنوات
واطولها امتدادا واكثرها سكانا واخصبها
واغناها واشهرها تاريخيا وابعدها ذكرى
امتد على سهل يقع شرق الدهناء وغرب عاليه
نجد او ما يسمى بالدرع العربي
وجنوبا بين الربع الخالي ونجران
وشمالا ينتهي بالزلفي في نفوذ الثويرات
فامتداد من الجنوب الى الشمال حوالي 800
كيلو متر ومن الغرب الى الشرق يتراوح مئه
كيلو الى خمسين كيلو متر واعلى قمه فيه
تبلغ حوالي 1500 متر فوق سطح البحر طبعا
[موسيقى]
واذا استقبلته من جانبه الغربي رايته
منتصبا سامقا تلوح صفحاته البيضاء ورعانه
الشم وشماريخه الفارعه كما قال الشاعر
شاعر المعلقه عمرو بن كلثوم
فاعرضت اليمامه
وشمخرت
كاسياف بايدي
مسلطين قال تعالى
واررنا جهنم عرضنا جهنم يومئذ للكافرين
عرضا ثم ياخذ في الانحدار التدريجي مشرقا
حتى يلامس السهوله الشرقيه عند الدهناء
وبه فجاج متباعده طبيعيه ما بين كل فج
واخر مسافات متقاربه في القدر جعلها الله
سبلا للماره ومنافذ
[موسيقى]
قال تعالى وجعلنا في الارض رواسي ان تميد
بهم وجعلنا فيها فجاجا سبلًا لعلهم يهتدون
وفي هذه الفجاج الطبيعيه في هذا الجبل جبل
العارض هي من الشمال الى الجنوب نبدا
العتك ثنيه الشعيب ثنيه لحيسي ولحى
والاوسط ونساح وثنيه نعام وبرك والهدار
وتمره والفاوض اما الطرق التي شقتها حضرات
اليمامه في جبل الطويق او جبل العارض من
جهه اليمامه والرياض فهي ثلاث طرق طريق
ابا القد وهوشهرها
وطريق مصيعط
وطريق المنجور
على درب من دروب اليمامه على القديه او
ابى القد صعدت قوافل التجاره والحجاج
وايضا الجيوش وعلى هذه الدرب دخل فريق على
خطى العرب الرحله الثامنه من مدخل حجر
اليمامه الاشهر في تاريخ الجزيره العربيه
[موسيقى]
اسم
فللحجر معنى الملك واليمامه منسوبه لطائر
اليمام ومنها خرجت زرقاء اليمامه تبصر من
مسافه ثلاثه ايام محذره قومها مرات ومرات
الى ان حدث يوما لم يصدق فيه الحاكم ما
رات فوقعت الكارثه
[موسيقى]
اتيا من الحجاز الى حجر اليمامه استوقفه
جبل العارض مهيبا شامخا يستقبل بريق الشمس
في اللحظات الاخيره من عصر ذلك اليوم لمعت
واجهه الجبل كانها سيوف مسلوله من اغمادها
مرفوعه نحو السماء هنا رسم الشاعر عمرو بن
كلثوم صوره خلدها بابيات يخاطب فيها رجال
اليمامه
فاعرضت اليمامه وشمخرت كاسياف بايدي
مسلطين
تظل الصوره الخياليه العظيمه التي خلدها
الشاعر عمرو بن كلثوم عن جبال العارض عن
هذا الجبل الشاهق من اعظم الصور واصدقها
في معلقته لما قال هو اتى من الغرب يريد
اليمامه يريد حجر اليمامه يريد سوق حجر
يريد ما يريد
وصعد من درب ابا القد لماذا لانه قال لما
اتى منها هنا
وراى هذه الصفحه وراء هذه الصخور الواقفه
كانهم رجال متقابلين او مدبرين معهم سيوف
راجلين طبعا ليسوا فرسان فقال
فاعرضت اليمامه وشم خردت
كاسياف بايدي مصلحتينا فالسيوف مصلى ليست
في اغمادها تظل هذه من اعظم الصور وليست
صوره خياليه فقط
وصعد من طريقه بل قد
ووصل الى الرياض وحصل له قصه هناك واسر
اسرته بني حنيفه وذكر اليمامه في شعر
سنذكره عندما نذهب الى اباظ الى اباظ
سنذكر ماذا قال عمرو بن كلثوم
في معلقته قال شاعر القصيده الواحده عمرو
بن كلثوم ابياته عندما تعلقت عيناه وقلبه
بالعارض فتحول الجماد بكلماته الى حياه
وتحرك الجبل مقبلا اليه في ذلك الزمان لم
يكن ابن كلثوم يعرف ان ما حدث له لرسم هذه
الصوره الشعريه هي الباريدوليا التي
افسرها العلم الحديث برؤيه صوره في الجماد
يراها صاحبها دون سواه سمي طويق على وزن
فعايل الا وهو تصغير الطوق والطوق هو ما
يحيط
بالرقبه وفيها احاديث كثيره ان الله يطوق
يوم القيامه من اخذ من الارض ما ليس له
نعم
الحمامه
الحمامه البريه التي اثارت الشعراء لها
طوق على الرقبه انظروا يطوق الرقبه خط
اسود من غير لون الحمامه
لكن لكن طويق ليس مكتمل الاستداره ليس
مكتمل الاستداره انما ربع استداره فسمي
طويق لانه ليس مكتمل الاستداره هذا طويل
اما الحمامه التي تعيش ايضا في هذه
المنطقه هذه
اعطانا اياه المحافظ على البيئه الاستاذ
عبيد العوني لها طوق كامل شبه كامل على
الرقبه هذا طوق الرقبه ولذلك هي تسمى ذات
الطوق هذه الحمامه الجميله
تسمى ذات الطوق وطويق تصغير لطوق لانه غير
مكتمل الاستداره
ولك ان تطيري الى جبال طويق ايتها الحمامه
الجميله
هو انت وهذا كله من فضل الله ثم فضل
الاستاذ عبيد العوني تريدين ان تذهب الى
جبال طويق
وتفرخي هناك تفضلي يلا يلا
[موسيقى]
اثارت الشعراء والهمتهم وتحدثوا اليها
وترقبوا الاخبار منها حتى سالها الشاعر
العباسي ابو فراس الحمداني ان كانت تشعر
بهمه وحزنه وطلب منها مشاركته همومه عندما
اسر في القسطنطينيه اقول وقد ناحت بقربي
حمامه ايا جارته هل تشعرين بحالي وفي
القصيده نفسها التي اخرج فيها عميق مشاعره
يقول الحمداني هيا جارته ما انصف الدهر
بيننا تعالي اقاسمك الهموم تعالي
مع الاستاذ عبيد العوني من المنافحين
المشاركين في الحفاظ على البيئه ودائم
بجبال طويقي مع هالشعبان ويدخل في هذه
الريعان وعالم بالنباتات والحيوانات التي
في يا استاذي ما هي النباتات ولا الشهر
اللي في طويق والحيوانات المنقرضه
والموجوده فيها تنوع بالاشجار جميل جدا في
بعضها مهدد بالانقراض ونادر مثل الحوره
الفراتي مثل ايضا الغافه الاحمر وهذا
يتميز في جبال طويقه اللي قال الشاعر عسل
الحياه يسكي لنا وادي الغاف من 200 سنه
القصيده هذه دلاله على اهتمام في هذه
الشجره ايضا فيها سمره الحطب اللي هو على
شكل كاس وايضا في سمره ديانا الضخم الجميل
وايضا عندنا الطلح عندنا ايضا السرح
والسلم ايضا بالنسبه هذه للنباتات فلنذكر
الحيوانات البريه طبعا فيها تنوع جميل جدا
غزال الادمي غزال الجبال واي الوعل وهو
المتسلق الرائع في هذه الجبال ولا ننسى
سيد هذه الجبال وهو النمر العربي نعم متى
وجدوا ومتى قبل سبعين سنه كانت قصه ماسويه
ولكنها هذه الحقيقه قتل اخر نمر عربي قتله
الله يرحمه ارشود الخريف في جبال الحلوه
وهذا نعم جنوبا نعم نعم جنوب من جبال طويق
فهذا اخر نمر عربي قتل في هذه المنطقه ولم
يذكر بعدها نهائيا نمور عربيه
[موسيقى]
فايضا هناك الذئب هناك ذئب يسمى ذيب طويق
اللي موجود بالعروه يقولون ما بها اكبر من
ذيب العظمه طبعا هذا الذيب يتميز في
مميزاته من الذئاب الرماديه من الذئاب
العربيه ولكن الذئاب العربيه بعد بحث
وجدنا انها تختلف احجامها واشكالها وكل
منطقه لها ذيبها الخاص في هنا في هذه
الجبال كنت تشاهد الوكري السعودي للاسف
بدا بالانقراض والشاهين الجبلي ايضا
العقاب مثل العقاب الصغيره ميلاد رجل
الحوم الملك الطيور ملك الصقور للاسف الان
بدات بالانقراض والاختفاء تمام ايضا
الاغنام النجديه الاغنام العربيه كبيره
لايله الضخمه التي مرسومه في الكثير من
الرسومات والنقوش ولا توجد بالعالم الا في
العرب فسميت قديما الاغنام العربيه كبيره
ليلى في عهد الرسول اللهم صل عليه وسلم
سميت بالاغنام النجديه واذكرت ايضا في
الحديث اللهم صل عليه وسلم
[موسيقى]
تبدو كانها مغروسه في الجبل تكون حائطا
بارزا رفيعا يلامس السحاب عن تشكيلات جبل
العارض يقول علماء الجيولوجيا انها تكونت
قبل نحو 135 مليون سنه حسب التاريخ السحيق
لهذه المنطقه فانها كانت مغموره بالمياه
وبعدما انسحبت تركت احافير وحيوانات بحريه
متحجره دكتور عبد العزيز ابن لعبون عالم
الجيولوجيا في السعوديه يا دكتور جبل
العارض هذا كيف تكون ولماذا الصخور صخوره
لينا لونها يميل الى البياض ولماذا ارتفع
وصار مثل الجدار وما هذه المتحجرات التي
نراها وايضا فوق طويقه اللي هي عاصمه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الرياض مما تشرب
ما خزان المائي الذي تشرب منه وشمالا عن
الرياض وجنوبا عن الرياض
كثيره من اسئلتك يا عيد
لنبدا بطريق طويق صفه لهذا المظهر
التضاريس الجميل في جزيره العرب واعتبره
العمود الفقري جزيره شكله في الخريطه كانه
عمود فقري
او طائر فتح صدره في هذا المكان وجناحيه
يفتحان الى الغرب طائر جميل جيولوجيا
كان هناك بحر عظيم
ترسبت فيه الصخور الجيريه ترسبت فيه شعاب
مرجانيه مثل هذه
شعاب مرجان كالتي في البحر الاحمر
وتوجد احافيرها هذه الان لو تمشينا في هذا
المكان وجدنا هذه الصخور المرجانيه دليل
على ماذا على انها بحار ضحله جميله عاشت
فيها شعب المرجانيه قبل 160 مليون سنه
الصخور بشكل عام هي هذه جيريه
تتكون كربونات الكالسيوم وفي الكثير من
الاحافير والقواقع وما لذلك طيب ما الفرق
بين هذه الصخره وهذه الصخره هذه بيضاء
وهذه بيضاء
ولكن هذه جيريه لو وضعنا عليها حمض
وجدنا انها تتفاعل مع الحمض اللي هو صخور
الجيريه اي نعم
كيف انه يتفاعل معها نعم بدات بينما
بينما هذه لا تطيش هذه رسوبيه كلها رسوبيه
لكن هذه احجار الرمل وهذه احجار جير هذا
يقودنا الى الاجابه على سؤالك الاخر من
اين تشرب الرياض
تشرب بالرياض من مصدرين الاول 60% من ما
تشربه الرياض من المياه المحلات في
المنطقه الشرقيه
واربعين بالميه من خزانات جوفيه من متكون
المنجور
والجلح
هذا واحد ومن البياض والوسيع احجار رمل
مثل هذا
كم هي غاليه قطره الماء في الرياض
طيب الجبل كيف ارتفعوا صار شاهق زي الجدار
هنا من جهه الغرب جبل العارض جبل طويق
سؤال جميل جدا تخيل ان ارض مستويه فيها
طبقات ارض متوازيه ثم جت حركه ارضيه
رفعتها فكانت كالقبه
اذا ارتفعت فشققت شيء طبيعي ثم تنهار
وتاكل عوامل التجويه فتصبح هذه كانها كما
تراها الان عباره عن جيلان واذا اتيت من
الغرب الى الشرق تجد جيلان كثيره جيولوجيا
جبل طويقه يتكون من اكثر من متكون احنا
نقول جبل طويل شيء لكن جيولوجيا جبل طويتك
يتكون الجزء الاسفل منه من متكون ظروما
متكون طويق متكون حنيفه متكون جبيله وكلها
تعمل او تكون هذا الجال الجميل اللي هو
جال طويل رائع شكرا جزيلا دكتور حياك الله
شكرا حياك الله شكرا الله يرضى عليك
خلف جدران هذا الجبل يقف تاريخ طويل ضارب
في القدم واخر قريب يحكي قصص حجر اليمامه
قصص معارك ومعاهدات وملاحم حدثت في
اوديتها وعلى هضابها حكايات انتصارات
وهزائم منها الصادق ومنها الكاذب عن جيوش
وعلماء وشعراء
جميعهم غادروا الا العارض
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات